welcome all to the Whitney and Betty
mcmillan sent
is at Yale we're delighted to host
General James Jones as this year's
George Herbert Walker lecturer in
International Studies and I should say
that at the conclusion of today's
lecture which will be right right about
5 30 there'll be a reception upstairs to
which everybody is invited the Honorable
George Herbert Walker the third Yale
class of nineteen fifty three and former
US ambassador to the republic of hungary
established this lecture series in 1986
in memory of his father a distinguished
graduate of the Yale class of 1927 the
walkers lectures is a signature lecture
presented every year at the Macmillan
Center and has often been one of the
most interesting events that we have put
on in the past lectures have included
Madeleine Albright John Major Richard
Holbrooke mamphela ramphele and many
others during his military career
general Jones served as commander the us
European Command supreme Allied
commander in Europe from 20 through 2003
to 2006 and commandant of the marine
corps from 1999 to 2003 he retired from
the Marine Corps in 2007 after 40 years
of service in the military but after
retirement Jones remained involved
involved in national security and
foreign policy issues in 2007 he served
as chair of the Congressional
independent commission on the security
forces of Iraq which investing
investigated the capabilities of the
Iraqi police and armed forces later that
year Secretary of State Condoleezza Rice
appointed him a special envoy for Middle
East security and he served as chair of
the Atlantic Council from 27 2007 to
2009 when he assumed the post of
national security advisor a position
that he held until
last year the title he has chosen for
his lecture today is national security
in the 21st century I'm pleased to
introduce General James Joan welcome
general thank you very much for that
very kind introduction and really is an
honor to be here especially to be
reunited with two people that I have
come to admire very very much ambassador
and mrs. Walker who did such a great job
in Europe at a critical time when
Eastern Europe was still feeling its way
towards his membership in the North
Atlantic Treaty Organization in its
assimilation into the the western part
of Europe and as a former NATO commander
I can assure you that we were very
grateful to have that dedicated
leadership of ambassador mrs. Walker in
Hungary these are difficult times that
we live in many many people talk about
the economic problems that we have and I
was there's a little piece in The
Washington Post the other day about a
one of our congressmen who was walking
home from a late voting night from the
hill and was approached from behind by a
gunman who put a pistol in his back and
said give me your money this congressman
had had a very hard day and he turned
around and wasn't was in a combative
mood and looked at his assailant and
said you can't you can't rob me I'm of
the United States congressman you just
can't come up and pull a gun and tell me
to give me give you my money and the
segment looked at him said okay well
then give me my money
I chose this topic because I I think
that it's a extremely important to
understand a few things about where we
are in today's world throughout history
it seems to me that from Empires and
civilizations in fact to the survival of
every single human being on this planet
it has been very very closely dependent
on the ability of Nations and individual
people to understand the environment
that surrounds them in order to be
successful in in order to survive in
many cases and more importantly the
quality of being able to recognize when
one's an environment changes and what
one has to do in order to compete in a
new environment is critical and it's
more critical today than perhaps at any
time in our history today we live in a
time when our ability to not only
understand but perhaps even more
importantly adjust to changing global
environment will probably have a
profound impact and effect on the United
States and its role as a world power in
by the 50th year of this still very
young century this profound change will
affect the individual fortunes of and
aspirations of nearly everyone certainly
everyone in this room today especially
the younger members of the audience I'm
sorry to start off with what some might
think as a pessimistic tone but let me
add that by by nature I am an optimist
and I don't buy into some of the things
I hear talked about not only the United
States but elsewhere about doomsday
scenarios associated with regard to any
sort of the climb
in for the United States this country is
proven time and again that we are
resilient especially in the face of
adversity and especially in the face of
complex problems but i do believe as i
as i mentioned that we are at a critical
intersection in our history and that if
we are to take the right path at this
intersection there must be a clear
recognition of the challenges we face we
also need a clearer understanding that
the world we had so much to do with
creating during the latter half of the
20th century is changing faster than
anyone can imagine with very serious
implications that must be addressed but
my experience over a relatively long
career that the definition of change is
what we easily do to someone else it is
not easy to change what we do in this
individuals or as institutions or as
countries but we can't compete and we
can't be successful without implementing
change as environment changes and this
is true of individuals it's true of
businesses and it's true of Nations well
we know about the new environment that
we find ourselves in in the still-young
century is that the world is smaller
information travels faster the gap
between the haves and the have-nots is
increasing in the world that speed is
important in decision-making and we even
worry about things that we'd never
worried about we never really worried
about climate in the 20th century we
never worried about water supplies we've
never really worried about energy except
when the price at the gallon of gas at
the pump got a little too high for our
comfort but I remember of 1973 when it
got all the way up to a dollar a gallon
and what a crisis that caused we didn't
really worry about economics as a
national security issue in those days
but nowhere is the need for change more
evident than in the area that we refer
to as national security if you consider
that just a few short years ago national
security was the exclusive domain of the
Defense Department a small portion of
the State Department and the National
Security Council which is generally also
a fairly small group of people in the
national security world of the latter
part of the 20th century we face
asymmetrical symmetrical challenges of a
bipolar world that had compared to today
a sense of order that no longer exists
if you look back and you think about the
serious problems of the 20th century
especially towards the end of the
century it was easy to diagram it was
easy to understand that institutions
that we created from 1945 until the year
2000 to deal with the world as it was
were very effective and we should all
celebrate that because it was this world
that we inherited coming into the 21st
century so during the latter half of the
20th century institutions both national
and international were created to deal
with the challenges of that world and by
and large things worked out rather well
if one uses the absence of nuclear war
between the United States and Soviet
Union is a benchmark for success and
precisely when the 20th century ended in
the 21st century began in terms of
dramatic change is the subject of much
discussion today but it was certainly in
my mind around the time that the soviet
union dissolved this was an event of
historical proportions that took place
without so much as a shot being fired
and this was also a fact that historians
will continue to be amazed by for many
many many years much was made of that
period in terms of what the future might
pretend when the dissolution of the
bipolar world
happen predictions of global peace
turning swords into plowshares some
voice concerned about the impact of an
unrivaled united states even French
newspapers referred to us as a hyper
power in short the long-term prospect
for global peace and tranquility seem
possible certainly within reach but a
funny thing happened along the way to
the new century the positive side
several nations took stock of what had
made the United States so successful in
the 20th century and started to imitate
that success Japan being probably the
first in and that was admittedly before
the end of the century but then most
recently China India Brazil the newly
reunited and reformed Europe perhaps the
emerging so Russia perhaps other
countries that are reforming in
themselves and but today we face an
unprecedented competitive challenges
from these newly reformed nations who
have established very close links
between their public and private sectors
you've recognized it in the globalized
world the ability to make rapid
decisions at the national level with
regard to their economies is an
essential component of any success that
they hope to enjoy down the road in
other words they've done or in the
process of doing what is necessary to
make themselves competitive in the 21st
century now whether that success is
temporary or long-lasting whether it
stands the test of time and the many
other challenges each will face over
time remains to be seen but clearly the
rise of pure competitors to the United
States is a major change to the world as
we know it and it seems to me that we
must deal with that challenge more
effectively than we are doing today we
have in place today many of the same
laws and regulations and policies that
were implemented during the last century
or export control policies are
they're slow they're overly restrict the
abilities of our business sector and our
corporations to compete in the global
market countries that wish to do
business with the United States are
discouraged by the layers of bureaucracy
that quote make it difficult to do
business with the United States and I
put that in quotes because this is
something I've heard for many leaders in
different parts of the world for the
last five or six years we live in a
world where Export Control reform is now
a national security issue there's
another example we've been trying for
the four years to pass the free trade
agreements between the United States and
three countries Korea South Korea
Colombia and Panama agreements that are
overwhelmingly in our national interest
without that agreements that we have not
been able to ratify without and due to
the smaller and purely partisan
parochial interests here at home indeed
institutions once thought of as being
timelessly efficient now seemed
paralyzed peer competitors challenged a
traditional world order core elements
that used to make up the national
security portfolio are more diverse
national leaders in most of our sectors
of our society are subjected to
standards expectations and immediate
criticism that in my view discourages
public service a condition that is not
in our national interest for the long
term internationally the global
have-nots are saying to their leaders
that they know what they are missing and
they are not going to take it anymore
witness the Arab Spring not too long ago
Tom Donohue president of the US Chamber
of Commerce said the following and I
quote America is not keeping up other
countries are signing trade deals
forging alliances to share natural
resources and are rapidly developing
their own domestic energy supplies some
are cutting taxes and regulations
pushing legions of young people through
science technology and engineering
schools and building brand new
infrastructure in a fraction of the time
it takes to build anything here unquote
in my view when a nation stops being
able to do the things that are in it's a
known own interests the signs of decline
cannot be very far behind trend lines
for our competitive positions in our own
hemisphere in Africa for example or not
encouraging the world is catching up and
there's nothing wrong with that but
there is still time to remedy the
situation but not nearly the time the
amount of time that some people think
there is it's interesting to note at
least from my perspective how little of
our current political discourse in
either party one year before national
elections is being accorded to the issue
of American competitiveness in the world
I know that it must sound strange for
someone who spent 40 years in uniform to
stand before you declaring that American
leadership in the economic sector of our
society is the biggest threat to our
position in the world during the 21st
century but I I believe that this is so
matter of fact I heard a line the other
day from a friend of mine in California
who said the economy in California is so
bad even the earthquakes are moving east
on the negative side and I fully
understand that my preceding assertions
were not exactly uplifting the ordered
world composed of two principal
adversaries has largely disappeared but
what has replaced it is not a
particularly good thing either we do
face a long term conflict that is best
described as a war of ideologies in
which throughout much of the
underdeveloped where we are portrayed as
the principal reason for oppression
either by our physical presence on the
planet or by our support to forms of
government that are not that are
considered oppressive by the people the
so-called Arab Spring phenomenon
represents just how complex and
difficult
things are on the global playing field
today the impact of these global changes
to our role in the world of the 21st
century are profound in the first place
I am I'm unsure that the body politic
has grasped the significance of the
difference between the two centuries to
be sure from a national security
perspective we have made some very
important changes that have contributed
to our collective safety and security by
combining the National Security Council
and the Homeland Security Council's we
have recognized that there is no border
where international and national threats
are concerned in other words you can't
delineate we're one stop starts and the
other one stops we created a flatter
National Security Council that is better
organized to address not only the
geographical challenges of different
parts of the world but also the
functional challenges of things like
cyber security economic development
development the linkages between space
Global Development terror and
conventional threats are integrated in
the National Security Council of today
and highly visible on a daily basis the
National Security Council itself across
the four layers of decision-making all
the way up to the full national security
council which is headed of course by the
president has been expanded to reflect
the fact that most of our governments
departments and agencies have to be at
the table when they need to be in other
words the smaller group of claimants to
the national security portfolio Defense
Department National Security Council and
a little bit of the stapler now have
have been expanded to include in
national security things like commerce
and trade and economic policies and
cybersecurity the war on terror and the
like it's the operating principle
beginning in january of 2009 that i use
to encourage the heads of different
departments and agencies to be at the
table in the Situation Room when issues
that they were concerned with were being
discussed the operating principle was if
you're not at the table you're probably
on the menu and so you'd better be there
nonetheless much more remains to be done
in terms of making the United States
more capable not only competing but
leading in the 21st century and this is
what it's all about one of the critical
shortfalls of our national security
portfolio for example is the continued
absence of any semblance of an energy
policy for the United States a condition
that has existed for over 40 years
surely this is a cross-cutting national
security issue of the first order at
best we have an a la carte policy when
from time to time the proponents have a
certain sector of our energy portfolio
broadcast and fund their opinions boone
Pickens comes to mind talking about gas
and wind and solar power nothing wrong
with that but the fact that we do not
publish a national energy strategy that
Americans can read and understand where
we're going with regard to the use of
energy and how we use it and what the
potential of the future is for our
energy needs is not only a national
failure it's an international failure
because other countries look to the
United States to lead in these sectors
and failure to lead only serves to drive
home the fact that the leadership that
we bring to the table is lacking this
may be an area where the private sector
will actually lead the public sector and
I believe that that at least for the
foreseeable future the paralysis that we
in the public sector and in the
discourses and debates and what it is
we're talking about is going to give way
to private sector leadership in order to
solve some of these problems to return
to the Arab Spring for a moment it's
important to realize that the the
traditional response package of the 20th
century which was usually purely
military in different parts of the world
is probably not what will be needed in
each and every crisis will face in the
21st century while each problem will be
different will have different
characteristics each will require at
least some diagnosis that includes some
thinking with regard to economic
solutions security of course and
governance these are remedies that will
most likely be applied by international
coalition's unilateral solutions such as
the what we used to do in the 20th
century could most likely have a
negative outcome if not applied with
great care and sensitivity we've take
the case of Egypt and this is a
developing issue that no one can really
predict how how it will turn out but
it's one that's extremely strategic and
very very important that it turned out
the right way in the early days of the
of the upheaval in Egypt the army played
a very critical role in in managing the
crisis in a way that resulted in many
people not being killed and hurt
unnecessarily the army advocated a
willingness to shift to to listen to the
people who were rising up and have a
lead Egypt towards more democratic ways
they immediately proclaimed election
dates which would have been postponed
several times
but the problem there if you look at it
to illustrate my point is that there was
no need to send in any US troops but
there is a great need for economic
development in in order to give the
people of Egypt a belief that not only
the United States but other developed
countries would would like to help them
solve these problems so there is a great
need for assistance with regard to
governance and rule of law stamping out
corruption in short the portfolio of our
response packages in the 21st century
will be different and it will have to
include those kinds of things and we're
struggling with that in terms of how to
reform our government because most of
the resources are invested in the
Defense Department some in the State
Department but to have a comprehensive
package that is required requires that
other agencies and are in our government
also have adequate resources in order to
participate one seems to me one need
only look at their frustrations created
by Afghanistan Pakistan and Iraq to see
that the future of each of those nations
may well be very different than what we
had intended at the onset of this decade
it's not to suggest that us engagement
is obsolete or even worse unneeded it is
most assuredly not in fact I think us
engagement is more important than ever
but it's the way we engage that will
have to be adjusted and the reason for
that is the sovereign governments have
sensitivities that are at an all-time
high and no one wants the scene wants to
be seen as block buckling under to the
US or any other country for that matter
and the other thing that's changed on
the global landscape is that as a result
of the pure competitors that we face
nations have alternatives that in
they didn't have just 15 years ago and
they use those alternatives very
skillfully playing playing us off
against others and others off against us
in order to do what's in their national
interest so the so-called American
Century of the 20th century is not
necessarily over there is no magic here
in terms of when it starts and what it
ends but the new century will be
different this is the world that our
young people will live in and compete in
we can't ignore it we cannot withdraw
from it as some would have you believe
and we cannot fail unless we're willing
to accept a lesser role for this nation
I am convinced that Americans still
expect that at the end of the day the
United States will lead the world in
most arenas not just the military domain
that was what led the Soviet that's led
to the Soviet Union's demise Soviet
Union was a superpower in one area only
and it wasn't enough and it is not
enough for the United States so to leave
you with an encouraging thought I will
tell you that after 65 years of
traveling the world over I'm convinced
more than ever that are many friends and
allies the world over do not want to
contemplate a world in which United
States place a diminished role they want
the United States to be the leader that
inspires those who are struggling or
suffering and who absent that leadership
would have no counter balance to the
world of the autocratic and oppressive
regimes so for our young people this is
your calling this is your mission and
this is your responsibility standing on
the sidelines is not acceptable you must
not only understand the severity of the
problem we face in a new and more
competitive global environment in a
still new century but also that you must
be part of the solution
yesterday I was in Johnstown
Pennsylvania at the request of the
family of the late of Congressman John
Murtha who died unexpectedly about a
year ago and the citizens of his
district 12 District of Pennsylvania had
erected a statue in his memory in doing
some preparatory work on what I might
say about the life of Congressman Martha
who not only rose to great power in the
house of representative is one of the
most senior chairman over a 36-year
career but he was also a soldier
statesman and that he also achieved the
rank of colonel in the United States
Marine Corps Reserve and participated
tried to volunteer during Korea was not
sent to Korea but served on active duty
in Vietnam and and distinguished himself
I think many times by being wherever the
troops were so he could better
understand the nature of the conflicts
be they be they in Vietnam or
Afghanistan or Iraq but I was struck by
a they saying that his great grandmother
told him when he was a young man and
that saying is now carved at in the in
stone and on the statue that we unveiled
yesterday in Johnstown and his mother
his great grandmother said to him you
are we are put on this earth to make a
difference we are put on this earth to
make a difference and we should remember
that we are free as individuals and as a
nation thanks to the collective
sacrifice of many who came before us and
will continue to be free as a result of
the next greatest generation you young
people here are that generation and I
predict that you will be amazingly
successful thank you very much for
listening to my remarks